-Here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns trying
to sing well-known songs.
We'll have most of the lyrics
in front of us on cue cards.
But when the music stops,
we'll only see a blank.
And it will be up to us to
finish the line correctly.
If you don't get the lyrics
exactly right,
the microphone in front of you
will spray water in your face.
[ Laughter ]
But if you can slay it
and sing all the words
perfectly,
then your opponent gets
sprayed in the face.
-I like it.
-Sound good?
-Let's do it.
-So we have our --
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have our safety glasses on,
because safety is sexy.
-True. Very true.
-Nick, you are up first.
Go ahead and hit the button.
Let's see what song you get.
-Ooh, I'm nervous.
-Come on, give him a hard one.
-May the best man win.
-Yeah, of course I will.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's me.
[ Beeping ]
-Wha -- oh.
[ Cheers ]
I have heard of this song.
-One, two, three.
♪♪
[ Cheering ]
♪ I kissed a girl
and I liked it ♪
♪ The taste of her
cherry ChapStick ♪
♪ I kissed a girl
just to try it ♪
♪ I hope my boyfriend
don't mind it ♪
♪ It felt so wrong,
it felt so right ♪
♪ Don't mean I'm in love
tonight ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
That --
Yes!
That's a lot of water.
-Can we see that --
I can't even see.
Can we see that in slow-mo,
please?
[ Laughter ]
All right, my turn.
I will be singing what one?
Give me an easy one, please.
[ Beeping ]
"I Kissed a Girl."
-Mm.
-Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
-I know the song. Oh, gosh.
-Two, three, and --
♪♪
-♪ Tell me,
did you sail across the sun ♪
♪ Did you make it to the
Milky Way ♪
♪ To see the lights
had faded ♪
♪ And that heaven is
overrated ♪
♪ And tell me, did you fall
from a shooting star ♪
♪ One time I played guitar ♪
[ Laughs ]
[ Sad horn ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheering ]
-Oh!
-Who knows that --
who knows that line?
Everyone knows Katy Perry.
They know the whole song.
-I don't know that one.
-Oh, God. What is that line?
What is it?
"Without a permanent scar"?
-Oh, yeah, of course.
-Of course.
-All right.
Nick, it is your turn.
-Okay.
-I'm not gonna show
slow motion,
because it was the same thing.
[ Laughter ]
Go ahead and hit that button.
[ Beeping ]
Give him something tricky,
please.
-Oh!
-I know that!
I know that.
-You know this one?
-Of course.
Fall Out Boy is my --
they're my dudes.
-Do you want to take this
one then if you know it?
-Nah, I'll let you
play with it.
[ Laughter ]
-One, two, three, four.
♪♪
-♪ Drop a heart ♪
♪ Break a name ♪
♪ We're always sleeping in
and sleeping ♪
♪ For the wrong team ♪
-Doing good!
-♪ We're going down down
in an earlier round ♪
♪ And sugar,
we're going down swinging ♪
♪ I'll be your number one
with a bullet ♪
♪ A loaded God complex,
cock it and pull it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding ]
♪♪
-That was extra.
No. Oh, no. Hey.
That was a little --
-That is the lyric.
-I know, but that --
You put a little extra
mustard on that last one.
[ Laughter ]
That one was a little harsh.
That was like --
[ Laughter ]
My glasses almost flew --
dude, my --
my jowls were flapping around.
[ Laughter ]
Next time I'm gonna stick my
head out. All right.
Back to me. I can't see.
This is fun, is it?
-It's so fun for me.
[ Beeping ]
-I'm gonna get this one.
Get ready, dude.
Get ready for this one.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh... [ Chuckling ]
-Now you know I know this song.
I love this song.
-I don't know if you know
the words though.
-Oh, of course.
-Joe doesn't even know
the words.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Mumbling and humming ]
♪ I'm a sucker for ♪
Yeah, I got this.
[ Laughter ]
Come on, Roots.
[ Humming ]
♪♪
-One, two, three.
-♪ I've been dancing
on top of cars ♪
♪ And stumbling out of bars ♪
♪ I follow you
through the dark ♪
♪ Can't get enough ♪
♪ You're the medicine
and the pain ♪
♪ The tattoo inside
my brain ♪
♪ And baby, you know
it's obvious ♪
♪ I'm a sucker for you ♪
♪ Say the word and I'll go
anywhere blindly ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding ]
[ Laughing ]
-Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Say the word, I'll go
anywhere blindly"!
Look who's blind!
[ Laughter ]
Aren't you happy
you did this show?
-I'm so happy to be here.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! This last one here,
this is gonna be a duet.
-Okay.
-If we slay it, we're safe.
But either one of us messes up,
we both get sprayed.
You ready to do this?
-Let's do it.
-All right, here we go.
[ Beeping ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
-Oh, oh!
I can't see what it says.
-Oh, sorry. It says --
"High Hopes,"
Panic at the Disco.
-I just had to act surprised.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ High, high hopes for the -- ♪
-Got it. Got it.
-[ Mumbling and humming ]
I don't know if I got
this one, dude.
I feel real bad. I think
I'm gonna ruin it
for both of us.
[ Light laughter ]
I love Panic at the Disco.
-We can do this.
-All right, we can do this.
Here we go. All right, good.
All right. Ahem.
Roots, whenever you're ready.
All right, we can do this.
-One, two, three...
♪♪
-♪ Had to have high high
hopes for a living ♪
♪ Shooting for the stars when
I couldn't make a killing ♪
♪ Didn't have a dime but
I always had a vision ♪
♪ Always had high high hopes ♪
♪ Had to have high high hopes
for a living ♪
♪ Didn't know how but I
always had a feeling ♪
[ Singing over each other ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad horn ]
-That was right!
-You were wrong!
-Those are the real --
those are the real lyrics.
-Those are the words.
-Those are the real lyrics.
I agree with you.
We're the winners.
Me and Nick Jonas, everybody.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]